so you were like a baseball player you
played in high school and stuff like
that did you go to college and play
baseball i actually had a
scholarship out of uh high school to
university of miami so i played there
one year as a freshman and then
i wasn't playing at all so then i
transferred to a junior college in miami
miami-dade so you they wouldn't even let
you play
no why because you weren't good enough
for the team right that was bad right
wow were you a good hitter in college
i i was no not really i was okay okay i
had power and batting practice but in
the games i didn't do much
all right so listen to this okay so you
get out of college
yeah or whatever you didn't even
graduate college right you didn't finish
i graduated junior college so i have an
associate degree
okay so you went there because like you
you you bombed out a regular college
yeah okay
so you go there and then i guess does
someone tell me like as a favor
somebody let you sort of go tommy the
sword is really really close friends
with my dad
what does your dad do uh he's like a car
dealer and okay
you know and how does little shorter
know your dad they kind of grew up
together they're
they're from nars town pennsylvania and
he's your godfather right well
actually he's my little brother uh my
little brother's godfather okay so he's
close friend of the family
good friends so as a favorite to your
dad did you say to your dad hey dad can
you ask tommy lasorda if i can try out
yeah what happened was again i wasn't
getting any exposure any
right you know at all and and uh tommy
obviously with his connections he said
well
i'll have the dodgers draft mike as a
favor and it looks good on a resume like
if you go to a school like i could go to
university of florida right or something
yeah
well they'll say yeah you've been
drafted by a team so we'll give you a
shot to play
oh actually a calling card all right so
like you really wanted a shot cause you
felt hey maybe i am a good baseball
player
yeah i had the dream you know you had
the dream yeah but even though you
sucked in college
you kind of know deep inside like if you
put your mind to it you could be good
yeah i mean i i knew i had some talent
because i would go to you know
knowing tommy i would be batboy and
stuff for the dodgers when i was a kid
and i would hit in batting practice and
i would hit home runs and out of the
park and i'd be like
i can do this like the regular guys were
you getting nervous when you played
logical things yeah
you would get nervous definitely so
something was holding you back
definitely okay so let me understand
something
so lasorda says to you uh-huh
all right kid because you're i know your
dad i'll let you try but meanwhile the
sword would probably think you sucked
too
and it's just holding doing it and he's
just doing it reluctantly get it out of
the way he's like i wish the whole
goddamn family would leave me alone with
us already right
he's been calling his mark in ever since
yeah so he lets you like try out
and you try out and what do they do they
put you in like double a baseball or
something
you go actually goes uh rookie ball a
ball double a triple a big leagues right
so you were like in rookie ball
yeah all right which is like you might
as well you might as well you might as
well be dead yeah
okay it's the same thing as junior
college and when you go on rookie ball
do you suddenly
start to get good yeah what happened was
i bounced around a couple of years and i
didn't do much
and and then all of a sudden did they
pay you you did the debate my first
contract was for 850
a month but let me tell you something
that's a lot of money considering they
didn't even want you that's good money
yeah so tommy basically got your job for
850 a month it's almost like being on
welfare yeah because
it's a giveaway job it's like a gimme
job like you do with your friends yeah
and then you figure you know what that
age you know i was like 1920 i was like
you only have one time in your life to
do it i'm also trying to have fun with
it i could always work
later right of course all right so so
you then how do you get over the
psychological thing though that he's
having well what happened was i really
started uh
going to the gym and training i started
lifting i gained like you know
15 pounds right got stronger and then
when i finally got a chance to play they
said okay hey you're hanging around here
long enough
you're going to get one shot to play or
you're out of here good and then that's
the way to relax yeah
yeah exactly right but then that's funny
you mentioned that because i just
relaxed i said hey
you know screw it i got nothing to lose
nothing to lose having fun
and i hit 29 home runs in a ball wow and
bakersfield so does lasorda call you up
and go hey
maybe i wasn't such a jackass for hiring
you yeah you're starting to hit home
runs you're making me look good
to take it all the credit so that's a
ball then they put you to double a and
triple a
and then in triple a yeah exactly then
what happened was then i went to mexico
i played winter ball
right it was a big lift because i played
against a lot of guys that played in the
big leagues and
next year i went double a triple a big
leagues in one year wow
in one year and you start playing for
the dodgers and all of a sudden you
become this great player
just yeah even say that about michael
jordan because like michael jordan
wasn't so great when he first started
yeah it just was the classic like late
bloomer just right you know just got
calm and it's a confidence thing because
once you get to that situation
and you know you can do it that's that's
half the battle so then you're at the
dodgers and they realize how great you
are and people are coming to watch you
play and they offer you 80 million
dollars for seven years
80 million and you say no you say no
um well how do you say no to that how do
you say it really really
it was a lot more complicated you know
just negotiations kind of blew up and it
it was it there's a lot involved it was
just like i didn't
like the way the team was going the
direction and the way that negotiations
were carried out it was just kind of and
tommy wasn't there anymore
yeah and yeah actually they just hired
him back
was tommy pissed at you for not going
with the dodgers no it wasn't really a
thing because
i had one more year until i'm a free
agent after this year i could
you know sign with anybody if right the
mets don't sign me so it's kind of uh
it was kind of knowing that i could play
for somebody after the year
but it just wasn't so as soon as you
tell the dodgers you're not going to
take their crummy 80 million
and you're going to hold out because you
basically your philosophy is hey
i don't care i'll just hold out for more
for somebody i'll play for somebody but
it wasn't
but don't you as a player say to
yourself why not take the 80 million
right now
instead of holding out for like 100 or
120 million which hey
are you talking about it if the team
wins or not yep like why not take the 80
million because like that now i don't
want to jinx this or anything but
couldn't you get injured like tomorrow
yeah like if i were to get injured
god forbid i would probably have to you
know take a one-year deal somewhere to
kind of reprove myself and then
sign with somebody but so you could take
the 80 million today no do the mets
the mets probably love you because
attendance has gone through the roof
since you started playing for the mets
how long have you been playing for the
match now
and uh i got here i guess at the end of
may all right so when you want to take
this is what i don't understand about
baseball okay hold on a second got a
million questions
80 million dollars they offer you you
say no
so instead of just keeping you there to
play and keep drawing big crowds
they say hey you're not going to take
our 80 million screw you we're going to
trade you two
where'd they trade you to sure the
florida marlins okay like hey we're
going to put you in hell
yeah all right pretty much they put you
to the florida marlins which i don't
understand like why not just keep you
there and play out the rest of your
contract because then
they would lose me if i were to sign
with someone else at the end of the year
and not get nothing for me
oh i see oh so they can oh they sold you
to the florida marlins basically traded
me for like four guys
wow cool does that feel good yeah and
then the
i think the marlins traded me for three
guys so i've been traded for seven guys
so you're worth seven guys i guess like
one of you is seven guys
like i said i mean it was a matter of um
you know i'd done pretty well up until
that point i had a good contract so it
wasn't just
i mean it's hard to explain to people
it's not just the money but there was a
lot oh yes it
actually is a better situation because i
ended up here you know right where else
you say
in your life you get to play in the
prime your career and so did the demar
in new york so the marlins traded you to
the mets yeah they were completely just
downsizing everybody they were getting
right so you don't get any more money
from the match they just have to keep
paying
you but yeah but the marlins got a
couple of players from them yeah exactly
okay
so now you're with the mets and
attendance is going through the roof and
unbelievable
have they offered you any money to stay
with them they're talking about it but
i'm just gonna see what happens do you
think they're gonna give you the hundred
what do you want 120.
i don't know i don't know right now i'm
just we're just trying to see